Welcome back, our next guest believes
that gift wrapping is an art form
that absolutely anyone can learn, teach me!
Please welcome the world's most famous
gift wrap artist, Alton DuLaney.
Whoo! Yes!
(audience clapping)
I'm glad to see you got the memo
on the holiday garb, right?
I mean, we are twinning.
This is a great example, though,
about the importance of presentation,
and the same is true with your gift wrap.
Like if you're going to a party,
you want to dress up, you want to do your best.
It's a celebration, you want to look your best.
The same thing, if you're bringing a gift to a party
dress up that gift so it looks its best too.
Well, how do I do that?
Because I have to admit I am not a good wrapper.
So I want to show you a few ways
how you can really elevate
even just your standard box wrap.
So I've pre-wrapped these for both of us.
You see I've cut my paper so there's not a lot of bulk,
I have my flaps on either end going down
so everything looks nice and uniform,
there's no visible seams, but when you get to this point
there's a cute little trick you can do.
And I say, gift wrap is a snap. (snaps fingers)
Let's all do that together, including the viewers at home.
Gift wrap is a snap. (snaps fingers)
Where's Ross when we need someone
to do some sassy snapping, right?
Okay, but what you do is you take those snapping fingers
and you run them around the edge of the gift,
all the seams, and what this really does,
it really crisps up your corner
and really makes a tight, sharp gift wrap.
Wow. This is really working.
Super simple, and it really takes a gift
a little bit further.
Like my soft edges became really tight and pointy.
Sharp, and exact like that really helps a lot.
Now, much like getting dressed in the morning,
I believe to accessorize, accessorize, accessorize.
And so instead of just popping on a bow,
create something really cool.
So I've created these little, it's a pine cone,
it's some holly, you can pick something off the tree,
you know, you can get some,
a sprig of rosemary out of your garden that adds that smell
to the gift, as well.
I love that.
And then that just dresses it up
and takes it to the next level.
It shows that you spent a little extra time.
Our next wrap is if you're going to that,
if you're lucky enough to go to a holiday party
and you're bringing a bottle of beverage-
Cheers.
It's a great holiday gift
for the hostess, right?
Yes.
So I'm gonna show you how to wrap a bottle of anything.
And I know you're tempted to grab that gift bag
at the supermarket, don't do it, don't be lazy.
Here's a quick, simple way.
So what I've done, we've layered a layer of cellophane
and a couple of layers of decorative tissue paper here.
And now we're gonna lay down our bottle.
And now we're just-
So I'm leaving
a little bit of the bottom out?
Yep, you're leaving a little bit
of the cello at the bottom.
Little, okay. Oh, yeah, I see.
And then we're just gonna roll it up.
We're gonna add one piece of tape on the side.
Yeah, see, that's like,
mine has like 50 pieces of tape.
Well, that's okay too.
So tape the bottom so that the bottom is sealed.
Okay.
And now we set it up.
And so now we're just gonna cinch
around the neck of the bottle with a ribbon.
(Drew trills tongue)
Ta-da!
We've got our little ribbon on there,
I just do a half, wait not yet, just a little half knot,
'cause then we're gonna add something to this.
So you're gonna tie on-
(gasps softly) Oh.
A corkscrew here.
Yeah, that's money. That is money.
(audience clapping)
So smart. So, so smart.
A great holiday gift, any host is gonna love this gift.
And I want to show you one last little tip
of how to elevate your bow,
so you've done a great job with the bow there,
is how to cut that perfect little chevron
in the end of your-
Oh, yes! How do I do that?
Here's how you do.
You take your ribbon, you fold it in half,
and then you cut towards yourself without cutting yourself,
and it creates the perfect little chevron.
Ta-da!
Ah!
And it creates the perfect little chevron.
And then I can make
a perfect-
It's a puzzle piece!
Yes, it is!
They go together.
This is so awesome. Okay, I absolutely love this.
Well, nobody likes to get a paper cut
when they're gift wrapping
and believe me, I've gotten a bunch.
So this show is thankfully teaming up with Welly,
to protect our little Christmas paws.
That's right, Welly has the coolest first aid kits,
and handy dandy tins that you have ever seen.
So you have the bandage or the ointment that you need,
where you need it.
And these flex fabric bandages move with you and stay on
just like these beautiful wrapped gifts.
And guess what? Look at how cool this is.
I mean, this is something I would truly put out on my like,
sorry, Welly, I'm just gonna open these
'cause I want to show how like awesome these are.
_ Super awesome.
I mean, these are like
the first aid kits that you want out, not in.
So I'm really excited to tell you guys
that everyone in the audience is gonna go home with one.
Whoo!
(audience cheering)
And I'm really excited,
look at these!
_ Super cute,
I love the black one especially.
Something for everyone, right?
This is so beautiful.
Welly, thank you for making something
so beautiful and compelling.
Design, honestly, it boosts your mood. And guess what?
It has inside of it what you need,
while the outside looks so absolutely beautiful.
So thank you, Welly, for sharing these with all of us
and thank you for-
Thank you!
Helping me up my game
because design is important.
It is!
Presentation is important.
Ta-da!
And happy holidays!
Thank you, Alton. We'll be right back.
(upbeat music)